when you started to make films what were
your hopes for these films where were
you what were your hopes for where it
was going to take you were these just to
tell the story or you actually wanted to
have this be something that you made
money from when I first started I think
I got a little roped into what everyone
you know at first maybe gets ripped into
at least that I've seen through the
years is that you want to you know get
some level of acclaim you want to get
some maybe money out of it you know of
course you'd love to pay all your bills
with your films wouldn't we all and you
know it's that it's that kind of thing
and I think a lot of that it first makes
sense it's you know of course you'd want
to make a living off of this but very
quickly after making some films I
realized that wasn't gonna happen quite
as quick as I wanted and I think a lot
of times people get burned out I've seen
a number of filmmakers who I respect and
people who I've worked with in the past
who who make a good first film and then
you don't hear from them again and they
kind of subtly fade away and a lot of
time it's it's really not through a
fault of their own but it's just more
through seeing behind the curtain if you
will and kind of saying oh okay this is
not going to be a thing that just
happens overnight it's gonna be a thing
that happens over many years and it's
gonna be a thing that I'm gonna really
have to plug away at time and time again
and you know it's not a quick it's not a
quick trip you know it's a very slow
road trip a lot of times and it's got a
lot of stops and a lot of different
things you have to do along the way and
I think it's it's almost more of a
lifestyle sometimes than it is a quick
thing to fame or anything like that
but I think now I've settled into a much
better place certainly a much healthier
place for longevity which is
understanding that I can and will make
films wherever I find myself and I know
I have the means to do it the the
circumstances and little variables you
know do I have a big crew which I've had
in the past do I have a small crew which
I've done as well do I have no crew is
it just me you know it's all those
little factor
they always are gonna change and those
are gonna be you know your little Tetris
puzzles you're solving along the way but
I think it's knowing that you can pick
up the video game if you will and play
it you know you're always gonna have the
challenges in game but it's being able
to say no I can always play it you can
always do it wherever you are because I
think a lot of times people do get
discouraged and they say oh I can't do
this it's too hard I'm not gonna be able
to figure out those little challenges
there's too many variables and
roadblocks but I think it's
understanding that you know hey we live
in 2020 is as crazy as the world is one
of the nice things is that the world
allows you to go on the internet and buy
a camera and a mic and a light kit
cheaper than it's ever been and it
doesn't mean that it's gonna be easy to
make a film but just getting the
equipment that was the the biggest gate
that the gatekeepers had over all of us
in the past was that you know hey that
equipment that's more money than you're
ever gonna see that's more money than
you're ever gonna be able to you know
drop it once on a purchase so that's
gonna lock 99% of people out and now the
the gates open so you can at least get
through the first gate now realizing
okay there's more gates along the way
and that's what happens in film is kind
of realizing okay well how are you gonna
pull people together how are you gonna
pitch projects but but I think just
understanding that you can get through
that first gate that for years and years
and years so many people couldn't even
you know really get through it's pretty
empowering and so I think it's as
empowering is you'll allow it to be and
I think it's the type of thing where if
you understand kind of what's ahead of
you and you can take it at a pace that
makes sense to you because that's who it
has to make sense to at the end of the
day then I think you'll be okay what are
your thoughts on people burning out
after their first or second feature or
even a short because they went into debt
yeah yeah I've seen a lot of folks spend
enormous amounts of money on their first
film you know even short films
I have always tried to be very frugal
just in life I've always tried to you
know make sure I don't spend more than I
have etc etc I was just raised that way
that's how my parents raised me and I've
always tried to carry a bit of that over
to film I think there's like a
glamorization of oh I'm gonna you know
hey put it all on credit cards and put
the house on it and whatever and we'll
see what happens and and that's not
really glamorous like to me I think that
there's like a little bit of a sadness
there because you know we shouldn't have
to do that
we shouldn't have to you know bet it all
in order to make something happen
because you know what what are the
results if you do make it happen great
but maybe nobody sees it you know so
it's not even just making the film
itself it's you know will people watch
it will people find it will people
resonate with it so I always say you
know try to assess your risk certainly
you'll have to spend some money on a
film but I always advocate to spend you
know the the smaller amount that makes
sense you know make sure that you can
feed your cast and crew make sure you
can clear your locations make sure
you've got the gear you need make sure
you're not rushing because you know if
you're rushing it doesn't matter that
you spend all this money to get in that
beautiful you know house or location you
needed you're probably not gonna shoot
it the way you want it to so it's a lot
of times just being able to check those
basic necessity boxes but I think also
just designing your films to not need as
much like that's one of the things I've
always tried to do with my filmmaking
whether it's you know my first film son
of clowns it was about a circus and that
was the first thing okay well how do you
write a film about a circus with $2,000
well you have to change the circus so
the circus soon became a rinky-dink
family backyard circus that was falling
apart and that became part of the story
so then I've just kind of said okay I
can relax a little bit the circus is
allowed to look bad you know and it's
kind of part of the plot so it's just
sort of engineering things in ways that
I think are cost-effective and allow you
to still be creative but just maybe in a
different way than you and
have you ever talked anyone out of
putting things on a credit card or
discouraged someone um I try not to be
discouraging just in general you know if
someone really wants to do it I'm
probably not gonna be the one to stop
them you know if their mind is made up
but you know I do tell like younger
filmmakers I meet at festivals and just
other filmmakers as well just you know
if you have something you want to make
just just try to do the like diet
version of it just to see if you can do
it you know just as a proof of concept
because you know if you make it and that
diet version of your film is is great
then you can go for a full coke you know
you can get the full coca-cola later
maybe convinced you know someone to pay
for it but you know why try and do that
yourself you know that's always the
question you have to gauge and I think
some people feel that they have a
message that they have to get across and
that no one else is gonna do it for them
and no one else is gonna finance it for
them and a lot of times they're right
and and that's why I you know recommend
you know make your own films but but
don't go into debt doing it because I
think if you only can make one film then
that's not a career you know you've
almost shot yourself in the foot too
early so I think it's almost just about
playing the long game and being able to
say okay I made one film and I'm gonna
learn from it and I'm gonna you know go
through the festival circuit figure out
what festivals to go to which festivals
not to go to you know what to do with
promotion and then eventually you just
kind of have to let it go
and then hope that you learned enough
and saved enough worked hard enough to
make another one and I think it's kind
of through that consistent output over
many years that I think you'll build a
career um you know from yourself and
from your own you know wall if you will
essentially and I think that's more
interesting to me certainly than kind of
betting it all on one kind of big action
sci-fi film because I think the worlds
got a lot of those already
you